let me bring in - Marcus Lawrence the
Cowboys defense event you want to get in
on this argument is is Kawhi Leonard
better than LeBron James right now uh
I'm not gonna get into this argument
because I'm a LeBron James fan
look where he is playing um tremendous
leaders right now yes see I would still
take LeBron I I still think that he does
the incredible more often than Kawhi
does I think Kawhi is wonderful he's one
of those titles but this is a recency
bias because he won that title last year
and I think we look at Kauai have you
met LeBron no I haven't what position do
you think that he would play in the NFL
I think you'd be a great tight end I
mean he played wide receiver tight an
order quarterback you play D Anthony
who's the best basketball player on the
Cowboys best basketball player on the
cowboy see not as a trick question
because we had Rico gathers he used to
play basketball for Baylor but as a
right now I really can't call no names
off the top of my head gotta get in the
gym and see who's the strongest guy on
the Cowboys oh yeah what uh what's he
throw up on the bench
wait wait he throws up on the back yeah
he's in a good does he need people to
spot him nah that's pretty massive
that's pretty impressive did you watch
the game last night
what do you look for when you watch a
game like that you know I mean I ain't
really no see nothing remarkable from
both quarterbacks last night so you know
it was really you know no need to watch
the game it's a quarterback ain't
performing and
they don't get me nothing to look at
ain't really looking at nothing cuz I
only see you know office minor
quarterback you know give me the
quarterback you would tune in to watch
the quarterback that I saw in the lights
you know I probably tuned in to watch
that Prescott how he's running the
Cowboys offense and you know how he's
performing right now
okay what about opposition what other
quarterbacks aside from your own I
really don't like quarterbacks period
you know I see that Prescott because
he's on my team and I'm forced to like
him never hit him in practice I believe
so I believe I hit him last year in
Francis we we got into it what Ellis
that was the last time yeah but when you
like Aaron Rodgers when you face Aaron
do you talk to any of those guys
no definitely not no focus on how i'ma
rip his face off or what here I must
really know where yeah okay so you don't
tell him you're gonna rip his face off
it's just implied that you're gonna try
to rip his face off well I'm pretty sure
he he knows before he even comes
how long have you were you down you're a
Dallas Cowboy fan before you went to the
Cowboys right yeah that's correct
okay a lot of times it's your dad or
your grandfather you know somebody in
the family grew up a cowboy fan when
they were really good winning Super
Bowls and then they passed that down did
that happen to you yeah that's what
happened to me on my dad was a huge
Cowboy fan and it was no way possible I
was staying at his house being on a
Denver Broncos fan so he trained me a
real real well and I've been a Cowboys
fan up cents what was the family
reaction when you went to the Cowboys oh
man so much excitement so much joy to be
able to live out a long dream that you
know had it was such a
adolescent it was really you know
tremendous he used to Marcus Lawrence
the Cowboys defensive end next game will
be against the Giants did you ever get
comfort comfortable with that blue field
at Boise State oh yeah I mean it's good
if you're the home team on the blue
field because you get to play in blue so
it's like it's kind of hard on teams to
be able to see you in you know basically
you know everything starts to blend so
it was a you know a good part of my life
I still am amazed that that video went
viral of get the right Jersey son with
the kid we're in this hey Kuan Berkeley
Jersey wanted an autograph did you did
you have fun with that are you still
hearing from people about that I mean I
don't know now so trying to see you know
what the people talking about but I
guess you know my attitude and I feel
like Snickers rewarded me with the swag
change of the week just because my
attitude and hungry of a player I am so
I'm the seventh planet to get awarded
attained this season and yeah Ben baller
made the change
yeah I'm rocking it right now you can go
check out my ass around see me rock okay
what do you need to do to get the swag
trained you really got to you know be
the hungriest player of the week you
know this all throughout the NFL you
know sneaker and NFL did a partnership
where the hungriest Player of the Week
you know get awarded the swag chain made
by Ben baller so I mean I got awarded
this week I'm pretty sure that it should
be coming back my way next next week and
the following weekend you know at the
end of the season they're giving the
chain out to whoever the fans vote was
the hungriest Player of the Year yeah
gonna give it to their charity so you
know it's a big look you know promo for
me and
I'm decided to wear the tank then
ballers a big deal oh absolutely
Ben Molly is a big deal because he'd be
making these big old IC pieces that
[Laughter]
maybe hook a brother up here DeMarcus
posed to do that
all right I want nickers oh no I I mean
you I could wear the the swag Jane I
mean I could use some you no bling some
ices you might say I'm telling you you
gonna need some net curls to be able to
do this
well good luck against the Giants there
and maybe pull his Snickers out of your
sock
after a sack how about that well long
snicker pay for the bag DeMarcus thanks
for joining us we appreciate your time
thank you that's DeMarcus Lauren for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]